a Florida man now faces manslaughter
charges in the shooting death of an
unarmed black man he initially avoided
arrest under the state's Stand Your
Ground law police arrested Michael Drake
a yesterday for shooting and killing
Marquis McLaughlin in a parking lot
dispute July 19th Draco will appear in
court this afternoon Manuel Bojorquez is
in Clearwater where the shooting
happened
men well good morning good morning there
is a memorial here for Marquis
McLaughlin near the spot where he was
shot and killed Michael Drake acclaimed
self-defense and initially the sheriff
refused to arrest him but prosecutors
have now come to a different conclusion
and said it's not the first time Drake
ax had lashed out at someone in his very
same parking lot Michael Drake a period
point-blank is a cold-blooded murderer
former Keith McLaughlin's family and
their attorney Michael Drake his arrest
is just the first step toward justice
Michael McLaughlin is Marquesas father
it was something that should have been
done three weeks ago I'm just finally
glad the incident began when 47 year old
Rekha confronted McLaughlin's girlfriend
for having parked in a handicapped space
outside a convenience store
McLaughlin pushes Dracon who then pulls
a gun and shoots McLaughlin in the chest
McLaughlin can be seen stumbling back
into the store where he died
the Sheriff's Office did not arrest
Rekha at the time but Draco was charged
on Monday nearly four weeks after the
shooting court documents also cited
three previous incidents he was involved
in including allegedly threatening and
shouting racial slurs at another black
man after he parked in the same handicap
spot
Drake acclaimed he's shot McLaughlin in
self-defense he believed that McLaughlin
was going to come back at him that is
within the book ends of stand your
ground standard ground laws allow a
person to use force without retreating
to protect themselves the law was also
cited in defense of George Zimmerman in
the 2012 shooting death of unarmed teen
Trayvon Martin McLaughlin's death
divided the community for nearly a month
and triggered protests calling for an
end to the controversial law community
pulling together
and the like cuz it it hurt and I don't
think I will ever get over it he's my
hair the Pinellas County sheriff said he
supports the State Attorney's decision
to charged Rekha if convicted Rekha
faces up to 30 years in prison
John Manuel sang